Elena of avalor is quickly becoming one
of the most popular cartoons of the year
and it isn't too hard to see why despite
its popularity there are many things
about this show that we don't know tune
in to find out which up-and-coming
Disney actress is responsible for
Princess Isabel's voice first time at
the things make sure to hit that
subscribe button and give this video a
big thumbs up now let's jump right into
the voices behind Elena of avalor
princess Elena there's one thing we can
all agree on
it's that princess Elena has a wonderful
voice one of Elena's best traits is her
ability to sing in nearly every single
episode funny enough actress Aimee
Carrero has never been too confident
about her singing abilities regardless
of this she still manages to make Elena
very proud every time she busts out her
vocal cords Guerrero has been acting
since 2007 and has been a part of many
big productions one of her first roles
was the one of Mia in Hannah Montana
Carrero has worked on a handful of
Disney Channel original x' however she
isn't limited to them this rising star
has recently begun voice acting for
princess adora in Shira and the princess
of power so if you're in Elena of avalor
fan keep your eyes open for this
upcoming series Luisa if there's one
thing you should know about Luisa is
that she looks exactly like her voice
actress Julia Vera this character is
known for her optimism and dedication
she serves as a member of the grand
council and it was chosen by princess
Elena herself Yara is definitely the
perfect individual for her role as a
matter of fact she was chosen as Louis's
voice actress within 24 hours of her
second audition Vera who is in her 70s
couldn't be happier to play Alana's
grandmother especially since the cartoon
encourages young women to go after their
dreams
Vera's character appears in a total of
25 episodes making her the second most
important character of the series Luna
believe it or not but there are some
pretty big actors working on Elena of
avalor
take the Yvette's Nicole Brown as an
example this big-time celebrity has made
quite the name for herself in Hollywood
however she isn't one to turn down a
voice acting opportunity as a matter of
fact she's done voice acting for shows
like Family Guy
Bojack horseman and
anymore she is well known for playing
the role of Shirley Bennett's on the hit
TV show series community in Elena of
avalor case Brown plays the role of Luna
who is a magical flying creature with a
very sassy attitude
are you surprised to find out that she's
the actress behind Luna
if so wait until you find out which
oscar-winning actress is also a part of
the show francisco actor Emiliano Diaz
is also an important character in the
Elena of avalor series he plays the role
of Francisco who happens to be Elena's
grandfather this character has a
pronounced love for music justice and
duty he is a member of the Grand Council
and takes his job very seriously Diaz is
a Cuban actor he was well known for
playing the role of Vic Palmero on the
hit TV series George Lopez he is the
third most active character in the Elena
of avalor series with a total of 24
episodes to his name Gabe are you a fan
of TV series like lost in Oz Arrested
Development and Jane the virgin if so
you might already know a thing or two
about Jorge Diaz this American actor is
the voice behind Elena of avalor escape
while he might be known for playing in
the kids show Diaz isn't as sweet and
innocent as he appears after all he did
play the role of Hector Estrela in
2014's Paranormal Activity the marked
ones this versatile actor never fails to
snatch up an opportunity when he sees
one are you shocked to find out that
he's the actor behind the charming and
heroic character Gabe
Miggs if there's one celebrity who knows
everything there is to know about voice
acting it's Chris Parnell this American
actor is the man behind many of our
favorite cartoon characters Parnell
plays the role of migs in Elena of
avalor however he's only been showcased
in about 13 episodes don't know who this
talented man is right off the bat well
allow us to elaborate Parnell also plays
the role of Cyril Figgis in the
hilarious TV show Archer
he's been showcasing cartoons like
American Dad Rick and Morty and Samurai
Jack all in all this highly successful
actor is happy to be a part of the
popular show Elena of avalor
we playin come on Cruz you're on my team
all right you can't lose the Cruz
shiriki and now the moment we've all
been waiting for
you're about to find out which
oscar-winning actress plays the role of
the evil sharee key the highly talented
and sought-after Jane Fonda is the woman
behind the cruel and unjust tyrant Fonda
has appeared in a total of 10 episodes
however her character is not someone who
is easily forgotten most Elena of avalor
fans have no idea that a big star like
Fonda is a part of the production but
hey now they do this big-time celebrity
keeps herself busy by partaking in a
great number of movies and TV series if
you don't know who Jane Fonda is by now
you might as well search her up and
binge watch all of her movies cruise
when we said that some big stars were a
part of Elena of avalor production we
weren't kidding actor
Mario Lopez recently joined the Elena of
avalor crew when he accepted the role of
Cruz while Lopez might not have an evil
bone in his body
his character sure does he is a
conniving antagonist who betrays his
kind and joins the dark side Cruz only
appears in about 3 episodes however we
thought it's important to tell the world
that he is a proud member of this Disney
Channel show Princess Isabel so remember
when we said that a big-time Disney
Channel star was a part of the Elena of
avalor crew well we weren't lying the
talented and driven Jenna Artega
is the voice behind character Princess
Isabel Ortega has been acting since 2012
and has managed to make quite the name
for herself she got her big break when
she landed the role of Harley Diaz in
the popular Disney Channel show stuck in
the middle before that though she also
appeared on the hit TV series Jane the
Virgin the young star is definitely on
the rise after all her IMDB page speaks
for itself the American actress has
played in big-time movies like Iron Man
3 and insidious chapter 2 so in other
words the sky's the limit for the
inspiring Ortega which Elena of avalor
actor surprised you the most let us know
in the comments and that's it for the
voices behind Elena of avalor thanks for
watching and see you next time
you
[Music]